I am will and this is Tabata Tabata is
an high-intensity interval training
protocol that our professor in Japan
came up with in 1996 he created this 20
seconds of work 10 seconds of rest over
8 rounds what I can incorporate anything
across the board you can do with push-up
Tabata burpees Tabata
sit ups what CrossFit is done is they've
taken the tabata a timing protocol and
taken it into their bag of tricks Oh
what do we have we have 4 minutes what
can we do where can we increase this
athletes aerobic activity and actually
it will increase your anaerobic activity
as well because we'll throw in weighted
activities I really love Tabata because
it's short and sweet I can get in get
done and feel like I've actually had a
workout try it about it and get moving
this is your 4 minutes Tabata workout
alright guys so we are here there's a
lot of workouts we're doing chest and
tries right now so we've got box here
tell me what this is here for the plyo
box we use at a gym but we're doing
these at home you can obviously use a
coffee table or a chair okay something
stable the first thing we have is the
tricep dip on the box so you're gonna
set up
okay hands on the edge of the box
difficulty is changed by how far you put
your feet out so go on it easy I'm going
to keep my feet under my knees down and
up
I can use my legs here if this is way
too easy for you take your feet out a
little bit makes a little more difficult
here not being able to use your legs as
much
let's move number one next when I hit
the chest let me use the same platform
in your chair your coffee table or if
you have a biobots of your home awesome
and do a decline pushup
so feet up on the box in a nice plank
position you're gonna lower yourself as
far as you can until your chin hits okay
very difficult finding good
20 seconds 10 got you have four rounds
all right who's ready for a situation
here
find a difficult thing that you like
from a trial
ten seconds to get place all right so
your chest and try working out Tabata
style start off with 20 seconds of the
dips you can do these on this plyo box
or a chair coffee table whatever you got
handy fault like ten seconds of rest 20
seconds of decline push-ups on the bio
box etc contains rest you've got four
times
that's your upper body chest into my
workout make sure to subscribe so you
don't miss out on any other fighting
weight episodes